hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talking
about the Gram stain receiver the Gram
stain is a very commonly used method in
laboratory and medical settings it is
called a differential stain so that
means that it helps someone to
differentiate or distinguish between two
different classes of bacteria
specifically gram positive bacteria and
gram-negative bacteria for more
information on the differences between
those two types of bacteria see my video
on gram-positive and gram-negative
bacteria today we're going to talk about
the steps of the Gram stain it starts
with fixing a sample this is when you
have a biological sample that has been
heat fixed to the slide simply by
passing it over a flame this helps the
sample containing all of the bacteria to
stick to the slide through all of the
subsequent steps the second step is the
use of is the use of crystal violet dye
this is a purple dye that stains all of
the bacteria so you can see here that
after we use this crystal violet dye all
of the bacteria in the sample are going
to stain purple this is because crystal
violet dye associ
with peptidoglycan and all bacteria have
at least some peptidoglycan and their
cell walls now crystal violet is a
positively charged molecule and iodine
is a negatively charged molecule this
means that together they form a complex
iodine for this reason it's called the
mordant
it helps the crystal violet to link to
the peptidoglycan and gram-positive cell
walls because they have a much thicker
layer of peptidoglycan then these cells
after they've been treated with the
crystal violet primary stain and the
iodine mordant they are treated with a
decolorizing solution but the polarizing
solution is is it's usually some form of
alcohol that helps the crystal violet
and iodine to be washed away from cells
where they aren't very strongly adhering
these would be the gram-negative cell
walls that only have a very very thin
layer
peptidoglycan leaving the crystal violet
dye in the iodine and the gram-positive
cell walls which have that much thicker
layer of peptidoglycan so after using
this decolorizing solution you have the
gram positive cells still retaining that
purple crystal violet dye
and then you have gram-negative cells
that are suddenly colorless again so
that is from the decolorizing solution
at this point you can visualize which
cells are grande positives because they
have retained this crystal violet dye
out there using the colorizing solution
but then the final step is the use of a
counter stain saccharin which has a pink
color just to help distinguish further
between those two cell types so after
the use of safranin crystal violet is
still in all of the gram-positive cell
walls so that these are all still purple
stained and you can distinguish that
they aren't grande positive whereas the
gram-negative cell walls have taken up
this safranin counterstain making them
at the end of a procedure like this you
can see how it's fast it's inexpensive
it's relatively simple and one of the
reasons it's so useful in a laboratory
or hospital setting is it helps to give
what's called a presumptive diagnosis we
see that the majority of cells in the
sample our grand positive bronze so
purple gram positive rod-shaped bacteria
the most common are one of the most
common causes of hospital-acquired
diarrhea and adults
it's called Clostridium difficile and it
is a gram positive rod-shaped bacterium
it is the most likely cause of the
infection
those who the sample was taken from and
then knowing this information not only
do you have a presumptive diagnosis that
can then be confirmed through later
studies we also know what kind of
bacteria were working with which helps
doctors to prescribe the correct
antibiotic regimen to treat this
infection and so this is why a Gram
stain
works